ici non les français cette phrase frank
bauer l'a prononcée tous les soirs sur
la bbc radio de la liberté durant la
période d'occupation
il y a prêté sa voix retransmise sur les
5 millions de postes de radios
françaises et littérature parce que
c'était leur seul moyen d'avoir des
nouvelles vraies sur une situation
qu'ils les intéressait beaucoup c'est à
dire la fin de la guerre
donc on était la voix des équipes de qui
était encore en liberté qui pouvaient
s'exprimer librement
ce qui était disparu quelque chose
d'assez rare plus d'une heure d'émission
chaque soir d'information et de
divertissement
le général de gaulle lui n'avait droit
qu'à cinq minutes quotidiennes après les
cinq minutes
c'était le programme français de la bbc
c'est à dire nous étions nous des
employés des anglais et nous faisions le
programme français de la bbc comme il y
avait des sections qui faisait un
programme italien un programme espagnol
as programme allemand
parmi ses souvenirs et qui sur le tard
pas grand chose sur les fameux message
personnel est codé à l'intention des
résistants pour nous c'est message
n'avait été certainement important mais
nous n'avions aucune part ni dans leur
fabrication ni dans la compréhension des
bouts de papier qu'on était sur notre
table et qu'il fallait lire
[Musique]
engagé pour sa voix perçante frank bauer
n'aura pas le plaisir de percer ensuite
dans le jazz sa passion de toujours la
voix de son fils axel bauer connaîtra
quant à elle
torriente
[Musique]